[Music]
right now only 15 percent of you are
subscribed
but that number is growing so if you
enjoy the content please consider
subscribing to the channel
hey guys welcome to another installment
of harry potter theory
in this video we're going to be
discussing hermione
the sorting hat and the hogwarts housing
system
more specifically we will be answering
the question
why wasn't hermione in ravenclaw as we
know
there are four hogwarts houses
gryffindor hufflepuff
ravenclaw and slytherin each house has
defining characteristics
and at the beginning of a student's
journey at hogwarts they are assigned to
one of these four houses
based on how well the students own
character traits mesh
with the principles of the house the
assignee of the hogwarts houses
is the fabled sorting hat a filthy
old frayed dirty hat that once belonged
to hogwarts founder
godric gryffindor the hat is extremely
outspoken
and is praised by professors and
students alike for its uncanny ability
to assign houses
to hogwarts students the hat is a
sentient being
that originally belonged to godric
gryffindor
and was bewitched by all four founders
godric gryffindor helga hufflepuff
rowena ravenclaw
and salazar slytherin before the hat's
existence
the founders would manually sort
students into houses
however after some time they realized
that the selection process would outlive
them
so they created the hat to continue
tradition the
founders of hogwarts recognized that
they each valued very different virtues
virtues which ended up leading to the
defining attributes of each house
it was important to them that the houses
they founded would continue to follow by
the beliefs
from which they were based these virtues
or
inherent characteristics can be summed
up in the sorting hats own words
a thousand years or more ago when i was
newly sown
there lived four wizards of renown whose
names are still well known
bald gryffindor from wild more fair
ravenclaw from glen
sweet hufflepuff from valley broad
shrewd slytherin from fenn
they shared a wish a hope a dream they
hatched a daring plan
to educate young sorcerers thus hogwarts
school began
now each of these four founders formed
their own house
for each did value different virtues in
the ones they had to teach
by gryffindor the bravest were priced
far beyond the rest
for ravenclaw the cleverest would always
be the best
for hufflepuff hard workers were most
worthy of admission
and power-hungry slytherin loved those
of great ambition
while still alive they did divide their
favorites from the throng
yet how to pick the worthy ones when
they were dead and gone
twas gryffindor who found the way he
whipped me off his head
the founders put some brains in me so i
could choose instead
now slip me snug about your ears i've
never yet been wrong
i'll have a look inside your mind and
tell where you belong
the hat uses legitimacy the art of
magically navigating through a person's
mind
to assess the student's traits after
placing the hat on your head
it will begin to analyze your mind and
place you in a house based on how
closely you resemble
one of the four founders if the hat
senses great bravery
gryffindor is the likely choice if the
hat senses great intelligence
ravenclaw is a likely choice if the hat
senses that someone is a hard worker
hufflepuff is a likely choice and
finally if the hat senses that someone
is hungry for power
then slytherin is the likely choice but
one thing that i've always wondered is
if intelligence is a defining
characteristic of ravenclaw
then why wasn't our very own hermione
granger in ravenclaw house
in the years that she spent at hogwarts
she was widely considered to be
the brightest witch of her age time and
time again
she displayed lateral thinking quickly
adjusting to her circumstance or
environment
and overcoming all sorts of obstacles
not only that
but she has an inquisitive and practical
mind which allows her to constantly
challenge the status quo
frequently introducing new approaches to
conventional methods of spell conjuring
or potion making
she just exudes intelligence on so many
levels
so again why ravenclaw when hermione
first placed the hat on her head in the
philosopher's stone
it wasn't an easy decision for the hat
and took quite some time to decide
funnily enough hermione is actually
asked why she isn't in ravenclaw in the
order of the phoenix
the exchange is as follows how come
you're not in ravenclaw he
terry boot demanded staring at hermione
with something close to wonder
with brains like yours well the sorting
hat did seriously consider putting me in
ravenclaw during my sorting
said hermione brightly but it decided on
gryffindor in the end
very rarely every 50 years or so to be
exact
a hat stool will occur during the
sorting hat ceremony
this is when the sorting hat needs
additional time to come up with the
decision
usually it is considered a hat stall
when the decision takes five minutes or
longer
this usually occurs when a student has a
personality
that could be considered equally
suitable for each of the hogwarts houses
mcgonagall faced a similar situation to
hermione in her earlier years
and the hat deliberated for five and a
half minutes
on whether she should be placed in
ravenclaw or gryffindor
the same houses that it considered for
hermione
i think this tells us that mcgonagall
and hermione are very similar people
while hermione did not quite reach the
hat store mark she was close
at a time of four minutes this tells us
that her levels of bravery and
intelligence
are probably quite comparable it's also
worth noting that in the case of a hat
stall
the hat may take the student's personal
preference into consideration
for its decision in the philosopher's
stone on the hogwarts express
she shows a clear preference for
gryffindor over ravenclaw
i've been asking around and i hope i'm
in gryffindor
it sounds by far the best i hear
dumbledore himself was one
but i suppose ravenclaw wouldn't be too
bad as the hat was struggling to place
hermione
it's more than likely that it used her
preference as one of the deciding
factors
we know the defining character trait of
gryffindor to be bravery
something that is exhibited by the trio
time and time again
throughout the series but is hermione
really braver than she is
intelligent she'd have to be pretty
brave and does she really value bravery
over intelligence while it may seem like
hermione values intelligence above
all an exchange between harry and
hermione in the philosopher's stone
reveals where hermione's priorities
really lie
i'm not as good as you said harry very
embarrassed as she let go of him
me said hermione books and cleverness
there are more important things
friendship and bravery than
oh harry be careful if it was ever
ambiguous
i think this exchange definitively
determines which values hermione holds
closest
this line by itself shows that she
values the traits of gryffindor
courage and bravery in a higher regard
than the traits of ravenclaw
intelligence and knowledge and she
doesn't just value these traits
she exhibits them time and time again
throughout the
harry potter series her courageousness
and strength
truly shine through in a number of
situations she's been in and decisions
she's made
these situations include but are not
limited to
putting herself in harm's way and saving
ron from the devil's snare
in the philosopher's stone stepping in
front of a
then unknown serious black in the
shrieking shack
under the impression that he was there
to kill harry accompanying harry to the
department of mysteries
despite strongly opposing the idea
staying with harry
even though she loved ron when the trio
disbanded in the deathly hallows
on the hunt for horcruxes and most
notably when she had to erase herself
from her own parents memories a task
that would require all of the courage in
the world
now it has been speculated that the hat
has a tendency to place
students in houses based on the
qualities they value
and not necessarily the qualities that
they actively personify
additionally the hat can detect nascent
qualities in a student
and generally places them in the house
that will challenge them the most
putting their character to the test a
good example of this is neville
longbottom
i think that hermione is an equally good
example of this
as when she started at hogwarts she was
actively exhibiting the behavior of a
stereotypical
know-it-all based on this alone one
would assume
the hat would choose ravenclaw but it
detected that deep down
hermione's inherent characteristics more
closely meshed with gryffindor
it knew to place her in the house that
would bring these qualities out
as she was already very studious and
intelligent
it made more sense that she would be
placed in gryffindor as she would have a
lot more opportunity
for personal development gryffindor had
a lot more to offer her
one thing that's for sure the hat
insists that it has never made a mistake
and always backs its original decision
regardless of whether or not the student
acts in accordance with the values of
the house in hermione's case
i think that its decision to place her
in gryffindor
was the best decision that it could have
made
and that's it for this video i hope you
enjoyed it please remember to like and
subscribe
if you guys enjoy the videos which house
do you feel hermione truly belongs in
was the sorting hat right after all
until next time
you're a wizard harry
[Music]